TRAVELED TO KABUL, WHERE AFGHANS
HARBOR A DEEP RESENTMENT OF THE
UNITED STATES FOR INVADING IN
2001 AND OCCUPYING SINCE.
>> Reporter: THERE WERE NO TEARS
HERE WHEN U.S. FORCES LEFT
AFGHANISTAN.
THE LANDSCAPE IS AWASH WITH
WHITE FLAGS, MARKING THE GRAVES
OF TALIBAN FIGHTERS KILLED IN
BATTLE.
AMONG THEM IS THE SON OF THIS
MAN.
THIS IS YOUR SON?
HE TELLS US HE WAS KILLED DURING
A U.S. SUPPORTED AFGHAN SPECIAL
FORCES NIGHT RAID ON THE FAMILY
HOME IN 2019.
VIDEO OF THE AFTERMATH SHOWS THE
SCALE OF THE DESTRUCTION, AFTER
A PROTRACTED GUN BATTLE, THE
HOUSE WAS LEVELED, KILLING A
SECOND SON AS WELL AS A NIECE
AND DAUGHTER.
THERE WAS A LOT OF BLOOD
SPILLED, A VOICE SAYS OFF
CAMERA.
THE REBUILT LIVING ROOM IS NOW A
SHRINE TO THE DEAD.
>> WHAT WAS YOUR REACTION WHEN
AMERICAN FORCES LEFT A YEAR AGO?
"I SAID THAT PEACE HAS COME TO
AFGHANISTAN.
THERE WILL BE NO MORE MOTHERS
BECOMING WIDOWS, LIKE OUR
MOTHERS AND SISTERS WHO WERE
WIDOWED AND OUR CHILDREN
KILLED."
ACROSS THIS RURAL TALIBAN STRONG
HOLD, AMERICAN FORCES WERE SEEN
AS INVADERS, WHO BROUGHT DEATH
AND DESTRUCTION WITH THEIR NIGHT
RAIDS AND DRONE STRIKES.
PEACE HAS BROUGHT A CHANCE TO
AIR LONG-HELD GRIEVANCES.
AT THE LOCAL MARKET, WE'RE
IMMEDIATELY SURROUNDED.
EVERY HOUSEHOLD HAD AT LEAST ONE
FIGHTER, THIS MAN TELLS US.
AND EVERY HOUSE HAD PEOPLE WHO
WERE KILLED BY THE AMERICANS AND
THEIR DRONES, AND WE ARE PROUD
OF THAT.
HIS BROTHER IS BELIEVED TO BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR DOWNING A
HELICOPTER FULL OF U.S. SPECIAL
FORCES.
SO HE'S TAKING ME TO THE SPOT
WHERE HE SAYS HIS BROTHER SHOT
DOWN A CHINOOK.
IT WAS AUGUST 6, 2011.
HE SAYS HIS BROTHER WAS HIDING
BEHIND THE TREES AND SHOT THE
CHINOOK DOWN WITH AN RPG AS IT
REPAIRED TO LAND BY THE RIVER.
30 AMERICANS WERE KILLED, THE
SINGLE GREATEST LOSS OF AMERICAN
LIFE IN THE ENTIRE AFGHAN WAR.
THERE WERE A LOT OF
CELEBRATIONS, AND NOT JUST HERE,
HE TELLS US.
IT WAS A BIG PARTY.
I'M SURE YOU CAN UNDERSTAND THAT
IT'S HARD TO HEAR THAT PEOPLE
WERE CELEBRATING ABOUT THE
DEATHS OF DOZENS OF AMERICANS.
"THIS WAS A HEROIC ACHIEVEMENT,
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE WHO WERE
KILLED ON THIS PLANE, THEY WERE
THE KILLERS OF OSAMA BIN LADEN,
AND SHEIKH OSAMA IS SOMEONE WHO
IS THE CROWN OF THE HEAD OF
MUSLIMS.
SO DEFINITELY PEOPLE WERE HAPPY
ABOUT THIS."
DAYS LATER, THE U.S. SAYS IT
RESPONDED WITH A STRIKE THAT
KILLED HAMAS' BROTHER.
ANOTHER WHITE FLAG RAISED IN A
VALLEY WHERE MARTYRS WERE MADE,
AND VIEWS HARDENED.
JAKE, WHAT IS SO STRIKING IS
THAT THE TANGY VALLEY IS LESS
THAN 50 MILES FROM KABUL.
SO MANY PEOPLE HERE WERE
DEVASTATED BY THE TALIBAN
TAKEOVER, A TWO-HOUR DRIVE AWAY,
PEOPLE WERE CELEBRATING IN THE
STREETS.
I THINK ONE SMALL PART OF THAT
IS THAT PEOPLE IN THE TANGY
VALLEY DIDN'T GET TO SEE SOME OF
THE BENEFITS THAT WERE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE U.S.
PRESENCE IN AFGHANISTAN.
THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT WAS
PUMPED INTO DEVELOPMENT AND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND RESOURCES ALL
AROUND, THAT REALLY DID NOT
TRICKLE DOWN IN ANY MEANINGF